How did a canine companion keep Steve-O sober?
Where did the part-time stuntman and full-time
troublemaker get his unmistakable voice? And
did he really go to clown college?
This is the untold truth of Steve-O.
For Steve-O, the path to "Jackass"
stardom began long before the show
itself. He told Forbes that he first began
experimenting with videotaping when his dad
won a camera from a golf tournament while
the comedian was still a teenager. Steve-O
took the camera from his dad's closet and used
it to film skateboard tricks with his friends,
discovering that he had a real knack
and passion for filming in the process.
It wasn't until after Steve-O went
to college at the University of Miami
that he got the idea to film more
elaborate stunts. He told Forbes,
"I spent more time partying and jumping off the
diving boards at the pool than going to class,
which was why I got dumped by my girlfriend."
In the midst of heartbreak, Steve-O turned
back to filming and started to videotape
himself performing dangerous stunts.
The reactions he got from people who
watched his tapes convinced him to drop
out of school and become a performer.
Steve-O's stint at the University of
Miami wasn't the end of his education.
He later attended the Ringling Bros. and Barnum
& Bailey Clown College with 32 other classmates.
Steve-O told Graham Bensinger that he got the
opportunity to work alongside another group
of clowns on a cruise ship. The job only
lasted a season, though, because, quote,
"there was a clown mutiny." The other
clowns didn't get along with Steve-O,
and they all threatened to leave if he returned
for another season, so the management fired him.
Luckily, the job also gave Steve-O the
inspiration for a major stunt. Standing on stilts,
Steve-O would light his clown suit on fire, then
have a unicycler ride through his legs while
a skateboarder jumped over his head and through
a fireball that he spit out of his mouth.
For the finale, he'd chug a beer and tip over.
Steve-O called Jeff Tremaine to pitch him the
idea, and they filmed the stunt as a pilot for
MTV. The station refused to air the stunt but
liked the idea and Steve-O
enough to create "Jackass."
Who knew that being an over-the-top stuntman
could land you in jail? Steve-O found out the
hard way in July 2002, when a performance at
a nightclub in Louisiana very nearly landed
him behind bars with a felony. Two of the stunts
in Steve-O's performance came back to bite him.
First, he received a principal to
second-degree battery charge for
"presiding over" a stunt that ended in a club
bouncer knocking a college student unconscious.
Then he got a felony obscenity charge
for stapling his scrotum to his thigh.
After much negotiation, First Assistant
District Attorney Mark Rhodes said that
the prosecution agreed that Steve-O hadn't
been an active participant in the battery
and that his scrotum stapling was, quote,
"more than likely protected under free speech
when conducted in front of paying adult
patrons." Steve-O avoided the charges and
a trial by agreeing to be on probation
for one year, donate $5,000 to a local
shelter for battered women and children, and
to never perform in Terrebonne Parish again.
The Louisiana incident wasn't the last time
one of Steve-O's stunts led him into legal
troubles. In fact, he was arrested again,
this time in Sweden, just a few months later.
He swallowed a condom full of marijuana and
snuck it through customs as a stunt for the
"Don't Try This At Home" show he and his fellow
"Jackass" members were performing in Stockholm.
Steve-O's fans know him as a stuntman, and some
even know him as a stand-up comedian, but not
many people are aware of Steve-O the rapper. Back
in 2011, he recorded and released the album "The
Dumbest Ass---e in Hip Hop" to not much fanfare at
all. The CD included a bonus DVD of more Steve-O
content and a poster of the album cover that read,
"Never before has a rapper been so ... dumb."
With tracks like "Crack Cocaine" and
"Poppin' Off," it's no surprise that
Steve-O's album didn't break the charts, but
that was likely never his goal to begin with.
Even Steve-O's fans more or less forgot the
album entirely the moment it was released.
Steve-O never released a follow-up album, and it
doesn't seem likely that he ever will, but fans
can always go back and enjoy one of the stranger
moments in the stuntman's career for themselves.
Steve-O went through a massive lifestyle change
in the late 2000s. After years of performing
wild stunts partially fueled by drugs
and alcohol, he decided to get sober,
and he's maintained that sobriety since 2008.
When talking about it, Steve-O makes what was
likely a lengthy and difficult decision
seem totally simple. He told Men's Health,
"Here's what got me motivated to change: I
hit a wall. I really reached a point where
thank god, my life got so bad that I had
to surrender to the process of recovery."
The process has entirely transformed his life,
and it's left him with plenty
of energy for more stunts.
Of course, no one goes through recovery
alone, and Steve-O credits his rescue dogs,
Walter and Bernie, with keeping him going. He
adopted his first dog when he first embarked on
the recovery journey in 2008, and he said it's
been good for him to, quote, "have a priority
that's not myself." Since then, Steve-O's dogs
have become his closest friends. They've helped
to deepen his connection with animals in general,
and that's also become a major part of his life.
Steve-O has been an outspoken
animal rights activist for years,
and sometimes he combines his passion for
ridiculous stunts with his love of animals to
powerful results. In 2014, Steve-O and
five of his friends changed a "SeaWorld
Drive" sign just outside of San
Diego to say "SeaWorld Sucks."
"If doing that was wrong, I don't wanna be right."
That got people talking, but not as
much as Steve-O might have wanted, so
the following year, he upped the ante.
Steve-O knows how to get attention, and climbing
a 100-foot crane certainly did the trick.
The machine hovered above Sunset
Boulevard, which gave the performer
the perfect spot to speak to the world through
a giant Shamu balloon with just two words on it:
"SeaWorld Sucks." At the top of the crane,
Steve-O set off a series of fireworks before
making his way back to the ground, where he
was promptly arrested. From the streets below,
law enforcement couldn't tell whether the man on
the crane was suicidal, so they deployed a whole
team to air on the side of caution — a helicopter,
five ambulances, and close to 100 firefighters.
Prosecutors charged Steve-O with five misdemeanors
that could have landed him in jail for more than
four years. He reached a plea deal for 30 days
in jail, three years probation, and a $14,000
reimbursement to the city of Los Angeles. In
the end, Steve-O reported for his sentence at
Twin Towers Correctional Facility, but he was
released after serving less than eight hours.
In addition to fighting for animal rights with
attention-grabbing public displays, Steve-O
also altered his own lifestyle to align with his
values. He told Us Weekly that he became a vegan
shortly after he started his recovery, and the
decision impacted way more than his diet. He said,
"I think it's benefited every area of my life."
Since that interview, Steve-O hasn't
gone back to his meat-eating ways, but
these days he says that he's not a vegan. He's
technically a pescatarian because he'll eat
fish and eggs from time to time. That's not his
biggest slip-up, though. He told Men's Health,
"I've been letting a lot of dairy slide too.
Even admitting that, I have a problem with that."
Despite having been a vegan himself,
Steve-O has also been critical of vegans
in the past. He wrote on Instagram,
"To all the combative, annoying vegans
who are choosing to attack me for not
forcing veganism on my cats, and for
not being a strict, militant vegan
myself […] maybe stop working so hard to pit
people who are on your team against you."
The post garnered plenty of backlash from some
vegan commenters, but Steve-O has
never been one to care about haters.
Every "Jackass" fan is familiar
with Steve-O's voice. There's just
nothing quite like it. He has the gravelly
rumble of a cigarette-smoking blues singer,
but he's sounded like that for over 20 years.
"I always thought that my world record for barfing
the most on television might
have something to do with it."
Over the years, he's also speculated that his
unique tone could have come from swallowing
glass or consuming copious amounts of
nitrous oxide in his younger years.
Eventually, Steve-O decided to consult with a
doctor to find out the root of his raspy voice,
and the answer wasn't at all what he expected. It
turns out Steve-O sounds that way because he uses
his throat muscles rather than his vocal cords to
talk. To prevent his condition from getting worse,
Steve-O started working on using
his vocal cords with a voice coach,
but he wasn't entirely sold on
changing his signature sound.
"I don't even know if I want my voice to
change. I kind of like getting recognized
over the phone — and my girl darn
sure doesn't want anything different."
"No, I love your voice."
Chances are, even if Steve-O
learns how to talk the
"right way," he'll continue
to sound like he always has.
After making his name as a stuntman,
Steve-O decided to stretch his abilities
and try out a new career path. He began
working as a stand-up comedian in 2011,
and he's spent the past decade touring
various shows and approaching stand-up
with the same determination he once
aimed at his stuntman ambitions.
Steve-O has completed two comedy specials:
"Gnarly," which was the first special he took
on tour, and "The Bucket List," which he began
touring just as the coronavirus pandemic shuttered
venues across the country. His stand-up acts have
always incorporated some of his stuntman roots,
but "The Bucket List" takes things to a whole new
level. Notably, he incorporates footage of brand
new stunts and stories into his act, creating
a multimedia experience for the audience.
Despite all the work that Steve-O has put into
his stand-up acts, he's had a difficult time
getting them out to anyone who isn't in his live
audience. He would gladly give the acts to a
streaming platform like Netflix, but so far, there
hasn't been any interest in his work. He spoke to
Graham Bensinger in 2019 regarding the possibility
of his getting a comedy special on Netflix that,
"They only want to give them
to the most prestigious,
pure, you know, lifelong stand-up comedians,
of which they do not consider me to be one."
In the same interview with Graham Bensinger,
Steve-O explained that he and his fiancée
Lux Wright met on a job that "never ended
up seeing the light of day." Even though
the project ended up being a failure, it gave
Steve-O the opportunity to meet the love of his
life. The two of them don't plan on ever having
kids, but they still have big plans for their
future — opening an animal sanctuary where they'll
eventually be able to live when they retire.
"You don't have to know us very
well to know that we love animals."
Steve-O told Bensinger,
"We want to have it in Southern
California, so we can drive to it."
Ideally, it would also operate as a bed
and breakfast that would give people the
opportunity to stay longer and develop deeper
relationships with the animals they're visiting.
Steve-O said he hopes it gives people pause the
next time they go to eat an animal for dinner.
He went on to explain that in the long term,
the sanctuary would also become a daycare for
children with special needs. Steve-O's
nephew has Down syndrome and autism,
and he has witnessed the stress his sister is
put under while trying to manage her career
and take care of her children. He wants
to be able to give back to parents with
similar struggles, and his fiancée is more
than happy to create that legacy with him.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite celebrities are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.